alors bonsoir à toutes et à tous merci
déjà toute l'équipe tedx ou ex
commandants de haut niveau de nouakchott
alors on est un peu tous sont exténués
je veux dire fatigué on attend depuis 15
heures alors on va la faire décontracté
tranquille comme on dit dans le jargon
n'est ce pas alors pour éveiller les
sens déjà on voit ça pour dire soi même
applaudir l'initiative en entier alors
je m'en vais me présenter contrairement
ce que je viens d'entendre ici je suis
pas produit depuis les tristes comme on
dit les tristes alors par le biais de ce
mot que j'aime bien j'ai créé ce qu'on
appelle ce que moi j'appelle ma les
tripes tude alors venir vous parler du
snam déjà me laissera la chance aussi de
parler du mouvement hip hop mauritanien
dont certains ne sont excusez moi du
terme
ignorant ou inconscient de son existence
depuis 20 ans 22 23 ans au niveau de la
mauritanie dont je suis membre fondateur
alors c'est quoi le slam c'est ce qu'on
fait depuis tout à l'heure on est parti
je pense bien de l'alimentation pour la
sauvegarde même de l'alimentation et de
la race humaine convient de faire
monsieur merci à monsieur dia ici des
applaudissements polis parce que je
l'évoquerai je vous ai repris j'ai vu
tout à l'heure
le pas par le grand-père le tonton qui
était la chaire sadou caméra que j'ai
repris dans l'aude metex justement
mal-être études ggg lui soutirer le
titre africa espérance pour dire que
dans une si longue lettre j'ai vécu la
peste dans un sens existent en latin
existentialiste du terme
tout comme l'enfant peul qui vécut comme
dans les champs de béton de l'afrique en
l'espérance pour aller vers l'enfant
peul que je suis c'est très compliqué le
slam à l'eau parlant de 2,2 tout ça
aussi et de rien on le fait des fois
quand je sortais tout à l'heure ma mère
m'a dit tu es ce que barack obama tout
comme l'eau
elle veut que je sois tout le temps
comme ça parce que
parce qu'elle est très mal perçue en
mauritanie c'est notre mot italien m
dans le melting potes dans le même telle
qu'elle est et nous on fait du rap très
mal perçu déjà au niveau interplanétaire
mais à certains qui sont dans
l'échappatoire certains qui essayait de
possibilités de par cet art en revenant
à la source même en allant dans le sens
positif pour rencontrer le grand
monsieur de grande demoiselle j'ai
entendu une fille tout à l'heure la
seule intervenante qui m'a fait penser à
un texte que j'ai alors si vous
permettez le passage déjà pour toutes
les femmes qui sont ici et pour la
patente qu'elle est parce que je suis
fan d'elle comme on dit aussi dans le
jargon avec judas tenir trop depuis que
je les écoutais tout à l'heure alors
quand je dis aussi parce que j elle m'a
repris ya beaucoup de personnes qui
meurent prix même monsieur germain
repris tout à l'heure alors quand je dis
femme reine fameux roi pendant qu'ils
paient névés ma voix pam qui stresse et
côtoie fin brain 20 broie femme qui
saignait merveille femme que je côtoie
que serré mon existence en amont aux
femmes qui pendant neuf lui aux portes à
haut risque dernier soupir avec tant de
bravoure alors la suite je vais pas et
venir
mais c'est ici que je les fais c'est ici
qu'il est fait j'étais là assis à côté
de monsieur aussi qui nous a parlé je
connais bien je les jeux les goûters le
moule taux qui en gagne et elle ne vous
inquiétez pas à vous tous je vais parler
au jeu de ce qu'on vient de voir vivre
ici ce soir on appelle l'amour tout qu
il a du talent
morteau t on dit morton est excellent
j'adorais g aller chercher l'huile parce
que il est bénéfique pour la santé
apparemment alors jeté là je sortais il
ya cydia ali que je remercie respect
m'offrait respect abbès qui m'a dit ex
tu bouges tu vas du dit non je suis là
depuis 15 heures pourquoi part attendre
jusqu'à 23 heures
problème alors j'ai mon stylo ition pour
preuve je regardais début tout à l'heure
et je me suis dit je vais faire un truc
exceptionnel ce soir je vais écrire ce
que je vis là mais ici même alors ça on
l'appelle et j'ai dit à mon petit garçon
jour répondant picot littéralement
français passement le bixi te plaît
il m'a dit papa dont huit arbitres
michel bui tech ou stylo alors ils
ramènent à la correction pour me dire
que ça s'appelle pas en bic
mais ça s'appelle au stylo alors je le
dis il s'appelle pas pigé le dis papy
non huit ans qu est-il aussi des coupes
le wikango il m'a dit plus on a pris car
il est plus
sans souvent portés par des poules est
comme ça j'ai commencé à écrire pour lui
et pour moi et pour tous les enfants et
surtout aussi une fois de plus pour les
femmes mais on va revenir à ce que j'ai
fait ce soir alors m'a plu mais là en
plus mais là j'ai écouté le premier j'ai
créé monsieur monsieur et respect à ce
grand monsieur parce que j'ai retenu une
date
j'ai retenu une date le 5 mars 1958
pendant votre intervention monsieur
c'est ce que j'ai reconnu et retenu
parce que j'aime trop parler de la
mauritanie jambes étaient précis croche
par la mauritanie je parle de la
mauritanie dans tous les sens du terme
et je parle là et on a une façon dans
les cultures urbaines de parler dans
l'art dans la joute oratoire slam dans
la poésie la thérapie slam la
psychologie cela remet la psychiatrie
slam parce que c'est des mots m
au ts qu'ils soient des mots et à unix
alors c'est ça c'est ça la puissance des
mots c'est ça le vert alors tout à
l'heure je l'avais avec moi j'ai tout le
temps avec moi je dis que j'ai encore
pris ma plu
pillée par des lacunes les rimes
parisienne tu n'as eu oui ce soir mon
livre est fade
oui mon coeur est malade mais je sais
pas là des mes oreilles sont en partie
oui
ce soir ma nature est un animal oui j'ai
mal je ne vous raconte pas la dernière
et quart temps mais jusque là m'a fait
mal il paraît qu'à paul il est une bande
et c'est vrai
oui ce soir il fait froid mais je sus je
perds ma voix les brèves du matin
bon suspendu lui ce soir il fait froid
mais je sus le stress mot côtoient mais
écrit on a déjà vu alors le temps
sidi ali depuis 15h me paraît lourd et
long ils n'ont pas lourd et long
oui mon inspire son fis dans les
bas-fonds de la science messieurs et de
la connaissance
les verts map en silence la toux mais
perdre
je pense je slame je suis là avec vous
je pense
oui
les verts mais attends silence je slame
donc je pense mes yeux à demi ouverte
offre un aperçu sur la misère du monde
algérie haïti chine caraïbes damas ya
main le malheur 90 dossiers liés à ciel
ouvert fouta walo bad guys are now prie
pour que la pluie ce soir a dit milieu
d'altitude j'ai vu la colombelle a reçu
une palme à kinshasa non à damas non à
bagdad non à bamako mais dit-elle mais
qu'à l'habitude là j'ai compris que la
paix n'est pas seulement une question de
plus petites mais qui n'existaient
vraiment qu'aux ciels d'habitude
oui
j'ai vu la colombe à timmy de d'aptitude
elle a reçu une palme dit elle mais
qu'elle n'est pas mortelle
alors là tu me quittes m
qu'elles se sont avides quelque 3 le
stress moi elle me câline et sans
vergogne me laisse lui je suis envoyé
par le spleen et de fou me traitera
l'autre que le cip litres en cycle will
et l'ap1000 et d'absolution
oui ce soir je ailleurs nulle part et
partout je sens une frayeur d'une part
on a tous c'est vrai que nous autres
artistes slameur on appui aérien et bien
qu'ici bas coûts nous disent que la paix
nous mènera au paradis je vois déjà que
ce texte devant certains ne vaudra même
pas un radis
oui même toi en rallye
qui comprendra six mots qui eux mêmes
font du mal alors la grâce à
l'omnipotent le tout-puissant l'âme de
l'ida et grâce à lui pour ce troisième
mais il ne suffit pas dans deux ou de
trois et pour comprendre que
l'intelligible pour l'homme est
inaccessible ce soir j'entends des
discours et des pleurs des appels au
secours une touchante au coeur serait-ce
le monde qui va mal ou bien que c'est sa
morale qui a l'accord d'autres oui je
suis en fou à cela mais des fois oui ce
soir un peu comme entre le marteau et
l'enclume j'ai le cogito qui est caché
sous ma plume
oui des fois je suis incompréhensible je
sois je suis x 24 oui j'ai dragué la
lettre sous la sueur d'une chandelle
alphabétique à bras le corps j'ai marché
josé chantier de notes alors j'ai mal
j'ai mal j'ai mal et je cela laissez moi
messieurs dames vous raconter l'histoire
une bien triste histoire une histoire
qui fait mal
parlant justement de morale parlons de
connaissances parlant de d'existence et
parlons d'amélioration les sports alors
on est au 17e siècle dans un village
d'afrique
là ce décor le théâtre de bien étranges
entretient en effet c'est ici même qu'à
basculer le destin volume à lobito à
l'homme aux yeux bleus aux cheveux
blancs flottant au vent entre dans un
village triomphalement la le chef
l'attend avec sa cour est tous ses
fantasmes ignore encore qu'il allait
traiter avec le malin le marchand de
chair le marchand d'horreur
alors il accueilli à bras ouverts avec
tous les honneurs et par internet
interposé
il se mit à lui proposer le plus les
chances de toute l'histoire de
l'humanité dit grange
oui moutou pas que oui ma que ces
miroirs sont pour lui tarde des dacquois
algérie
kounou l'eau
il a encore il reprend nous loana nous
le baiia tout il vaut 10 très haut
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelait que ces
miroirs sont pour vous
des pluies que c'est paul vi qui
l'appela détruit que ces colliers sont
conduits monique hautes plaines capi y
aborde en contrepartie table de femmes
et d'enfants solide comme touré lors des
razzias et pas des invalides
en un mot c'est la jeunesse de farafina
qui se vide à cause de la cupidité de
certains de ses chefs à vide des
millions de personnes souvent du onze de
ce parc faire du promis que nous réserve
le deuxième acte lui apte de seine 1
excusez moi collée au 20e siècle le même
paysage africain la l'esclave à change
de visage devient musulman
le les stars de la poule aux odeurs se
décide à berlin l'occident se partagent
comme au morceau de pain et pour le bien
de l'humanité ce continent doit d'être
civilisé tank colonisé lé peuple d'être
ensemble donc sans moralité on passe
ainsi de encore un homme aux yeux bleus
cette fois habillés en religieux il a
pendu à son cou une idole en fer forgé
pourtant ils nous prouvent taudis ville
en bois sculpté dites moi monsieur k via
petit guide est au paradis les brebis
égarées ou préparer les bras bien sûr
gorgi les paroles de la bible devienne
comme en lice qu'au mercantile il est
plus facile à un chameau lobbies est il
de passer par le trou d'une aiguille
quand riche d'entrer au paradis à
l'espoir des richesses et d'un garde
redit oui 3 et ma première scène
nous c'est le retour de la chique côté
des chiens pays par le peuple colosse
des chaînes travaux forcés effort de
guerre sur exportations minières tout
pour la métropole pour l'agglo des
misères
quand on te frappe sur la joue gauche on
ne tend pas la droite
oui troisième hat maintenant retournera
chicoter les chiens n'ont plus de gratte
ciel là le chef et sa cour au revient à
l'utc le président et ses ministres
l'habit blanc les multinationales le
sinistre la banque mondiale et autres
l'héritière de la coloniale punique
qu'on parle pas celle applique les mêmes
techniques celle de bourse de paris ou
de l'entente nous remarquer vaut pas que
c'est ici cno prend et ça n'a pas ou non
dans la pitance aux pauvres ventre
bayonnais le géant des peines pays genou
a battu bayonnais
l'occident encore par adam malysz
peuvent rien de parler qui descend
présidente reconnaît dans le parisien
j'ai mal à la fabrique oui il ya trop de
cerveau en fuite
j'ai mal à l'afrique dite moi
que nous réserve la science je peux
m'arrêter là pour dire que c'était tout
pour moi ce soir mais permettez moi
aussi de vous remercier une folle une
fois de plus parce que ça fait tellement
plaisir d'être captivant et d'être
captés comme je dis souvent c'est ça
l'islam et des fois où il fait mal des
five et resurgir des souvenirs et il ya
des fois où nous mène en bateau en
voyage c'est pourquoi je t'adore
tellement que à chaque fois que je me
mets à prester j'aime voir des sourires
des crispations des étonnements et des
remises en question ce but nous d
plus pour moments que j'ai passés durant
toute ma carrière j'en ai 20 ans et plus
comme nouveaux époux mauritanien alors
ce soir je me permets de dire que date
est retenue il soirée sera ancré en moi
alors merci à toutes et à tous et à très
bientôt je pense que vous avez bien peur
subventions merci beaucoup